Olá a natureza nós sabemos que é
incrível não é mesmo ela é tão sábia e
nos presenteia com uma infinidade de
alimentos cheios de nutrientes que podem
fazer uma diferença incrível na nossa
saúde e o vegetal sals é um verdadeiro
aliado especialmente paraa saúde do
nosso sistema linfático também do fígado
da nossa digestão e até da tireoide
muita gente usa o sals na Sopa em
saladas mas eu vou compartilhar com
vocês uma maneira de diferente e para
ser sincero uma das minhas favoritas
consumir o sals em forma de suco e olha
que não é qualquer suco não ele tem um
jeito certo de se fazer para que você
possa aproveitar o máximo todos os
benefícios bem o sals também conhecido
como IPO tem como nome científico apum
graveolens e é o mortalista bastante
nutritiva e bem fácil de encontrar aqui
no Brasil mas antes de mais nada Vamos
fal falar um pouco sobre porque o sals é
tão especial primeiro o sals é uma
excelente fonte de vitamina K que é
essencial para a congola sanguínea
adequada ou seja ajuda a evitar
problemas como sangramentos excessivos
um dos nutrientes mais interessante do
sals é o molibidênio esse mineral embora
necessário em pequeníssimas quantidades
é um óo elemento ele desempenha um papel
muito importante Vital especialmente no
detox de metais pesados do nosso
organismo e o que é preocupante é que
muitas pessoas estão deficientes em
molibidênio e não fazem a menor ideia
não não sabe nada disso E claro o sals
também é rico em outros nutrientes como
vitamina A vitamina C folato que é a
vitamina B9 magnésio potássio também é
uma fonte poderosa de antioxidantes
agora eu quero destacar um composto
específico do sals que merece toda a
nossa atenção nós estamos falando da
apigenina ela é amplamente estudada por
suas propriedades anti-inflamatórias
antioxidantes e neuroprotetoras então
esse composto Não só está presente no
sals mas também em outros alimentos como
é o caso da salsa o tomilho e a camomila
o que que torna então a apigenina um
elemento tão especial ela pode ajudar a
reduzir inflamação no corpo o que é
benéfico para diversas condições
crônicas como doenças cardíacas artrite
a apigenina possui propriedades
antivirais promissoras tá sendo estudado
para isso então em estudos tem sido
demonstrado a sua capacidade de inibir a
replicação de vírus como é o caso do
herp simples da Hepatite C da gripe e
epsen bar Então ela atua modulando a
resposta imunológica aumentando a
produção de interferons e pode bloquear
a entrada viral nas células hospedeiras
então estudos mostram que ela fortalece
os neurônios do cérebro age diretamente
na sinapse das Comunicações as conexões
entre os neurônios então desta forma
temos neurônios mais fortes o que se
traduz em uma melhora significativa em
várias funções cerebrais como é o caso
da cognição a memória e o funcionamento
Geral do cérebro então a apigenina
lembra desse nome apigenina o salão tem
doses bem interessantes desse composto
nos seus talos o que faz dele um
verdadeiro aliado pra saúde geral agora
vamos falar sobre Porque é tão
interessante consumir o suco de sals em
jejum pela manhã primeiramente o suco de
sals é um verdadeiro aliado na
desintoxicação do sistema linfático pra
eliminação de várias toxinas vários
resíduos que se acumulam no nosso corpo
quando o fígado está sobrecarregado de
toxinas isso afeta diretamente o sistema
linfático levando ao acúmulo de resíduos
no organismo então resíduos que são
ruins para nós o suco de sals entra em
Ação ele vai dar aquele empurrãozinho
essencial paraa limpeza dessas toxinas
tanto no fígado quanto no sistema
linfático Além disso ao fortalecer esse
Nobre órgão fígado o suco de sal pode
ajudar na Regeneração das células
hepáticas e assim prevenir a sobrecarga
desse órgão Vital melhorando as suas
funções Gerais e tem mais ele também
promove a produção de de bile que é
fabricada no fígado e é fundamental
paraa digestão das gorduras quando
falamos de digestão o suco de sals é um
verdadeiro amigo do nosso sistema
digestório ele é muito eficaz em
aumentar a produção de ácido clorídrico
no estômago algo que hoje em dia Muitas
pessoas têm em níveis baixos e a falta
desse ácido pode causar uma série de
problemas como refluxo indigestão e
desconforto após as afeições o suco de
sal ajuda a prevenir tudo isso evitando
sintomas como inchaço e constipação
também auxilia na proteção da mucosa
intestinal graças a sua potente ação
antiinflamatória ele pode proteger o
intestino da inflamação mas não para por
aí se você incluir o suco de sals na sua
rotina ele pode até beneficiar sua
tireoide isso porque o sals contém
antioxidantes e minerais são
fundamentais paraa função da tireoide
que ajudam a regular a produção de
hormônios Além disso el Combate o
estresse oxidativo que pode prejudicar
tireoide especialmente em caso de
tiroidite Hashimoto Então esse ataque
autoimune que as pessoas sofrem as
portadoras da tiroidite de Hashimoto ele
pode ser amenizado pelos antioxidantes
que estão presentes no sals isso vai
ajudar a proteger a glândula Nobre
tireoide se você também incluir outros
alimentos que protegem a tireoide na sua
dieta como as castanhas que são ricas em
selênio os benefícios podem ser ainda
maiores então alguns especialistas
defendem que o sals possui uma
propriedade especial única de combater o
vírus epsen bar o mesmo que causa doença
mononucleose infecciosa em algumas
pessoas que tiveram essa infecção o
vírus pode permanecer no organismo de
forma latente E com o tempo vai ter uma
predileção pelos tecidos da tireoide
podendo atacar o tecido tiroidiano e
prejudicar esse órgão então durante esse
estado latente o vírus não causa
sintomas de forma direta Mas pode
reativar se as condições como é o caso
do estresse da
imunossupressão outras doenças e atacar
tireode outros tecidos do corpo assim o
sals Poderia ajudar a combater esse
vírus latente no nosso corpo
especialmente se consumido regularmente
Além disso ele poderia ajudar a
estimular a produção do hormônio T3 que
é o hormônio ativo e produzido pela
glândula tireóide e como preparar então
o suco de sação é muito simples Você vai
precisar de um Masso de sal que deve ter
uma média de oito talos primeiro Lave
bem os talos de sals em Água corrente
para remover qualquer sujeira o resíduo
e depois que você fez essa limpeza para
facilitar na hora de fazer o suco corte
o sals em pedaços menores isso vai
ajudar bastante especialmente se você
for utilizar um liquidificador agora
passe o sals pela centrífuga ou se você
estiver usando o liquidificador Talvez
você precise adicionar um pouquinho de
água para ajudar a bater até que o sals
fique completamente
triturado bem pessoal tem que triturar
ou bater bem em seguida é hora de coar
use um coador fino ou até mesmo um pano
de algodão para remover a polpa se você
prefere um suco mais fino essa receita
rende cerca de 300 a 400 ml de suco um
copão perfeito para começar o dia e aqui
vai o segredo beba na hora assim que
você terminar de coar Esse é o truque
para garantir que você aproveite todos
os nutrientes fresquinhos do sals e o
melhor o salão É extremamente baixo em
calorias não causa aumento do açúcar no
sangue muito pelo contrário pode até
ajudar a estabilizar os níveis de Açúcar
isso faz do sals uma excelente opção
para começar o seu dia com leveza com
saúde com disposição o ideal é beber o
suco em jejum esar pelo menos 15 minutos
antes de tomar o seu café da manhã
habitual se você tomar o suco junto com
café da manhã ou com o lanche da tarde a
absorção dos elementos nutrientes pode
ser reduzida Tente fazer isso por 30
dias e observe os seus benefícios agora
o que mais você poderia adicionar esse
suco de sals bem o ideal é beber o suco
sem mais nada sem adicionar mais nenhum
outro elemento e quanto adicionar frutas
é é possível se adicionar frutas mas é
importante ser cuidadoso se você planeja
consumir esse suco de forma diária Eu
recomendo escolher frutas com baixo
índice glicêmico como é o caso das
frutas vermelhas ou coco essas opções
são mais interessantes para manter a
carne glicêmica sempre baixa mas isso
não significa que você não possa usar
outras frutas de forma ocasional de vez
em quando por exemplo adicionar uma maçã
ao suco de sal com cuina muito bem e dá
um toque refrescante além de fornecer
outras vitaminas pessoalmente eu prefiro
comer a maçã como fruta e tomar o suco
de sal puro porque que eu acho é mais
saudável e benéfico mas incluir uma maçã
no suco de sals uma ou duas vezes por
semana pode ser uma ideia assim
interessante uma ou duas vezes por
semana outra adição que você pode
considerar é o uso do Limão Associação
com o limão que vai deixar o seu suco de
sal ainda mais refrescante e saboroso
agora uma coisa muito importante que eu
quero destacar nenhum alimento por si só
faz milagre se alguém te disser que um
único suco vai resolver todos seus
problemas na vida pagar suas contas e
boleto desconfie Claro existe situações
de que uma deficiência de nutriente pode
estar causando algum problema específico
E aí claro que consumir um alimento rico
nesse nutriente vai te ajudar sim ok mas
na maioria das vezes o que precisamos é
de um conjunto de medidas de ações para
realmente melhorar a nossa
saúde Especialmente quando falamos de
doenças crônicas degenerativas então o
que que isso significa estilo de vida
saudável que nós batemos nessa martelo
todos os dias aqui o estilo de vida
saudável é a chave isso começa com
alimentação equilibrada porque o nosso
corpo precisa de uma variedade de
nutrientes nutrientes diversos
diferentes para funcionar bem então
muitas vezes um único alimento pode ser
rico em um certo nutriente mas ele não
vai conseguir suprir todas as suas
necessidades as necessidades do seu do
nosso organismo então por isso é tão
importante diversificar o que colocamos
o nosso prato Então meus queridos Muito
obrigado pela sua atenção um grande
abraço um beijo no seu coração Você é
fera